neither Steve coffin here today I want
to talk about pronunciation in Mandarin
Chinese some people may think that
Mandarin Chinese because you know the
Chinese language is from a very
different sort of language family than
say European languages and therefore
they assume that it's difficult to
pronounce and I think sometimes they're
thrown off by the tones of Chinese
actually if we leave tones aside for a
minute the pronunciation of Chinese
making the vowel and consonant sounds is
really not very difficult okay
the vowels they have you know pure
vowels and they have some diphthongs
basically and oh of course a big problem
in Chinese is that they do not use a
phonetic script they use characters
characters represent meaning there are
components in these characters that give
you a hint as to the pronunciation but
they're not that useful at least at
first when you start into the language
so therefore we rely on pinyin pinyin P
I NY I M is the sort of Roman alphabet
Latin alphabet form of Chinese which
gives us a hint as to the pronunciation
by and large the vowels that you read
and pinyin give you a good indication of
how those vowels are pronounced and you
just have to listen to a few times to
notice you know how they always
pronounced it ooh you know e ah whatever
might be not a problem
things get a little more complicated
because of pinyin things get more
complicated when it comes to certain
consonants so if I go off this list here
so most consonants are not a problem but
for whatever reason oh you know what in
a backtrack I was looking up information
on this and I came across this here
which is a box of flashcards that I used
50 years ago to learn Chinese
they are the best a thousand characters
the thousand most common characters
produced by the school where I studied
Yale in China I looked them up on on
Google and you can buy them for anywhere
between fifty to one hundred and
twenty-five dollars from different
sellers and resellers there really are
beautiful and on the face they have the
character with the what's gonna as a
radical which is a component in this
case mouth radical Co in red and on the
back they have various meanings and the
pronunciation the great thing about when
I learned Chinese was that they use the
Yale system of romanization so you are
looking at the back of this UN was YW ay
n um the problem with pinyin is they
have gone why you am and that tends to
make people go UN instead of you an okay
here we have a character that is
pronounced C cuz she the see see that's
another sound that's very difficult
because it's a little different from the
s that we have in English or in western
languages but even in Western languages
there are different SS like in Spain
have a very s push push rubber a push
very heavy s and different languages the
s can vary now the Chinese there is a
form of the S sound which in my yell
translator or at least transliteration
romanization they wrote it sy I which is
very helpful because it's kind of like
an S why I sound is si si you're hitting
a an I type sound before you actually
hit the I so does B whereas
unfortunately the opinion version of
that is X where's the connection so
that's why when we see C Jinping for
example the president of China most
people can't really connect the X I with
C kind of unfortunate
uh-huh anyway and and of course I'll get
into this later people want to put that
there's your sound everybody they call
him ji Jinping is si si Jinping so in
many ways the Yale romanization was
better the pinyin does things like give
you the letter X which is pronounced C
the letter Q say Q car q no letter Q is
pronounced chip cha now another thing
that opinion does to confuse you is that
you know you can have a consonant like
cha followed by E or ooh they have a new
sound in Chinese U as in French - and if
it's Chuck followed by I or II the
natural tendency is to say Chu or Chen
which is a slightly different CH sound
from like Cho and even in English church
is a heavier true sound than cheese so
it's quite unnecessary in my view to
have you know a CH which they use in
pinyin for cha and this Q when it's T
however that's what they do so you got
to watch for the X which is actually see
and that Q which is actually teach and
they do the same with Z H and J so
Beijing anytime you have then I or G the
ooh then it's a J that they use but if
it's a heavier like in English we would
make a difference between say jump and
jeans its ass the jaw is slightly
lighter and it happens naturally just by
pronouncing the word
so if you see Beijing you're gonna say
Beijing except there are some people who
are convinced that every je and Chinese
should be pronounced so even though we
don't have a joy in English the word
leisure is about the only place where
you find pleasure you find those just
sound in English but we have no letter
that represents there's just sound but I
can't believe the number of people who
want to pronounce Beijing which is
correct as Beijing okay not to mention
the fact that they want to call C
Jinping gee that's another matter
so here again if you just it's
unfortunate like Wade that least.not way
jealous but Yale as a Yale romanization
they would have written Beijing they
would have written doom like to moi is
China
to war pinyin has Z H Ong we don't have
Z H in English and it's not Jang Hwa
it's June war so actually pinyin is a
very unfortunate system of writing
Chinese however all you have to do is
get used to it so it really isn't a
matter a problem the other thing that's
not good about pinyin is a very
important sound in Chinese is the are
very similar to the North American are
or the Irish are are Ireland so to eat
is true now in my old Yale romanization
they would have written CH Archer or
derp derp derp derp derp sure but no
with pinyin it's an AI CH AI chit - it's
not it's true turn so that's also very
important so what you have to do is
follow the you have to use pinyin I mean
everything every form of romanization
for Mandarin Chinese is going to be
opinion so you have to listen to the
pinyin and identify just how these
different combinations are pronounced
you have to get used to fight by the way
that si is a top sound but that's
a number of European languages okay
duh Zed is a sound so you have to get
used to that so I think I like
personally I don't use the international
phonetic alphabet I don't know those
symbols I don't want to put the time
into learning them I think it's enough
to start out by listening to pinyin or
sees me reading PM opinion listening to
the words and getting used to how those
things are pronounced there is a
tendency even when you do that to be
influenced by the way it's written I've
often said this people have trouble
pronouncing English tend to be
influenced by how certain letters are
pronounced in their own language okay so
you have to get used to idea that it's
not John Wall it's Jun wall and really
wherever you see the jet age it's
actually a J alright and when you see
the Q it's actually a Chuck I want you
to see the X exactly a C and think of it
as s ye see it's that kind of a lighter
C again if you go to this Chinese pod
web page which I'll put a link to here
you can see she's got diagrams of where
you put your tongue I've never found
these kinds of diagrams to be useful I
think you just have to listen and get
used to it and then listen a lot
speaking of listening as I was digging
up all my old Chinese stuff you know oh
I have to get the tones too but this is
a box full of Chinese CDs a boxful I've
got you know philosophy I've got history
I got you name it and what I listen to
more than anything else I don't have it
here is Yong Chun comic dialogues why
because we have to we have to get a
handle on the tones so in English we
speak with tones we speak with tones we
have tones and other tones and so we
have intonation in Chinese they have
intonation but it determines the meaning
of a word when you learn vocabulary and
if you're learning an opinion and even
on my old cards here they would have a
marker for the tones like she okay UN
and so there's four tones
ma ma ma ma the fourth is a falling tone
and this is again described on that
chinesepod webpage and there are funny
rules like you know if you've got 2/3
tone mama it's active ma ma so you have
to learn that and sometimes a rising
tone becomes or at least the falling
tone becomes alright there's a few rules
there go and look at them but in the end
you won't be able to remember the rules
that well you won't be able to remember
that well the individual tones of the
characters you have to get used to
hearing them in combination learning
them as phrases just as we do in any
language and in that regard I found
listening to Chinese comic dialogue I
was going to show you some example here
we are yung-chun of which I have many
many many at home these are the best
because they sang strong performers tend
to exaggerate and you have to exaggerate
the intonation try to imitate that
intonation and if you do that you will
get the tones and you will get a natural
flow to the language but it means a lot
of listening and I would put the
emphasis on initially getting started
with opinion seeing how the pinyin works
some of its idiosyncrasies and then just
listening to a lot listening of course
to material that you understand because
it's very frustrating to listen to
things that you don't understand so
listen and read save words get to our
you understand certain things then
listen to it over and over again so that
some of these phrases become almost like
you know Buddhist chants in your brain
like your brain is really starting to
get the rhythm of the tones and if you
put effort into doing that then you will
conquer the mysteries of Mandarin
Chinese pronunciation but you won't be
perfect and you needn't strive for
perfection but you can strive for
constant improvement that's all I have
for you today bye for now
[Music]